salut si vous tombez sur ma chaîne pour
la première fois sachez que cette année
le 1er janvier je me suis donné pour
défi de faire une vidéo par jour pendant
un an pendant 366 jours sur youtube
après avoir fait mes adieux à mes amis à
ma famille à mon lit aussi je n'ai pas
trop vu cette année j'ai allumé ma
caméra j'ai sauté dans le vide de la
création en essayant de ne pas trop
perdre en qualité versus la quantité des
vidéos que j'allais devoir faire fin
janvier nous étions 500 abonnés sur la
chaîne vous étiez 500 à regarder les
vidéos et à me suivre et moi interagir
avec vous peut-être que vous étiez là
dit que moi si vous en faisiez partie et
je découvrais a game que je connaissais
pas de moi je croyais que youtube
c'était juste une plateforme pour mettre
ces vidéos en ligne et les partager sur
les réseaux sociaux par exemple j'aurais
pu d'ailleurs choisir n'importe quel
site pour faire ça je suis pas sûr que
ça aurait fait la même chose sur ma
dropbox mais bon quand je me suis lancé
ce défi c'était pour me stimuler dans la
réécriture de mon spectacle qui
maintenant est prêt à partir dans
quelques jours en tournée donc je ne
reverrai toujours pas ma famille
toujours pas mes amis et toujours pas
mon lit et si vous voulez venir me voir
jouer quelque part en france il ya un
lien dans la description qui vous emmène
sur toutes les dates de tournée au mois
de février j'organise une faq sur la
chaîne et olivier nicolau me lance une
vanille me mets au défi de me mettre à
nu sur la chaîne si un jour j'ai atteint
les 100 mille abonnés avant le 31
décembre
la bonne idée qu'on a là ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est qu'à ce moment là vous
êtes un millier de personnes à me suivre
sur la chaîne c'était déjà énorme
et c'était inenvisageable qu'on soit 100
fois plus d'ici le 31 décembre
donc j'ai dit oui en rigolant
aujourd'hui je rigole mois on y
reviendra dans quelques minutes
alors ça ça voudrait dire qu'on aurait
atteint les 100 milles avant la fin de
l'année donc je prends pas trop de
risques là pas de problème c'est un
engagement
olivier nicolau fin mars et mon pote
pierre cros qui m'invite à faire une
vidéo avec lui sur sa chaîne et là vous
êtes 17000 à me découvrir et à apprécier
au point de venir suivre mes vidéos
17000 monga 17000 c'est l'équivalent de
8 olympia en avril il ya la fameuse
bande de jouets stars vous souvenez de
ça ça m'avait donné une idée ce jour est
de parler de la cnv la communication non
violente dans une vidéo je me dis bon
ces patriarches ça va pas intéresser
grand monde mais je trouve ça important
de parler de la cnv un jour et c'est là
qu'on voit que j'ai du flair puisque
c'est la première vidéo qui passe les
100000 vu le prends moins thalys l'un
quand c'est des choses qui me concerne
je me plante tout le temps c'est aussi à
cette même période que vous
commencez-vous à sous-titré les vidéos
pour les rendre accessibles aux
malentendants je voulais vous remercier
pour ça c'est souvent les mêmes noms que
je vois passer quand je vais à l'élite
les sous titres je les ai pas dit à peu
près une fois par semaine et je vois le
même nom merci merci beaucoup bravo ne
lâche rien continuer c'est un grand
geste d'accessibilité que vous faites
pour les autres pour les huit derniers
mois j'accélère en juin il ya à l'aula
du bini lelas dubigny qui m'invitent sur
sa chaîne et en plus de ce marais elle
me fait découvrir à sa propre communauté
en août je vous fais un mois complet
denim trente deux énigmes et en
septembre je réalise juste des rêves je
rencontre bernard werber je fais des
feat avec des mecs comme romain de
teknion test comme amy make-up procom
crise de la chaîne poisson fait qu'on
est avec le grand william le seul
l'unique pas d'arcachon non doc seven
doc seven me fait passer dans une de ses
vidéos dans un salut internet et là
c'est dix neuf mille personnes qui le
jour même viennent voir mes vidéos
c'est l'ultime lancer ses doc c'est mon
parent peu de temps après on se retrouve
100 milles sur la chaîne du mental blog
chaîne qui je le rappelle j'avais fait
juste pour me stimuler dans la
réécriture et comme vous êtes adorable
avec moi vous m'avez bien mis dans lutte
dans la promesse que j'avais fait au
mois de février la mise à nu et moi je
vous ai dit qu'on n'y reviendrai que
pour la dernière vidéo de l'année la 360
6e c'est à dire celle ci bon gg j'ai
cherché la faille 1 quand même hein je
me suis dit que j'allais emmener ma
caméra et que j'allais la tournée à poil
il ya deux villes qui s'appelle toile je
veux tu as tourné là-bas à poil j'ai
cherché sur internet ça a déjà été fait
et puis au final je me suis dit non je
veux pas tourner autour du pot je vais
faire une vraie mise à nu celle qui
révèle tout vraiment tout bon y'a rien
de caché qui révèle tout tout tout tout
tout la mise à nu et pour tout révéler
il faut commencer le 22 novembre 1982 je
suis né le 22 novembre 1982 à marcigny
c'est un village à quelques kilomètres
qui est au nord de la rochelle à ses
taux quand j'étais très jeune j'étais
jaloux de ma grande soeur calais à la
bibliothèque et je réclamais à ma mère
de faire pareil je savais pas lire mais
c'était pas grave je voulais faire comme
les grands donc j'allais là-bas je
prenais surtout des bd pour commencer à
la même période on avait un voisin c'est
un vieux monsieur qui s'appelait jacques
il habitait à côté de chez nous et il
m'a proposé de m'apprendre un jeu à
chaque fois que je pouvais j'allais le
soir chez lui
se montrer très patient très très gentil
pour eux pour m'apprendre des choses
pour discuter avec moi il m'a fait
naître le goût de comprendre les choses
de savoir comment les choses
fonctionnent bref c'est devenu mon
meilleur copain pour jouer avec moi
puisque à 5 ans je connaissais pas deux
personnes pour jouer aux échecs de
manière avec moi et c'est à 8 ans que je
découvre l'univers de la magie du
mentalisme dans un livre de robert v no
qui s'appelle cours magique et c'est
aussi à cette période que je commence à
monter des spectacles pour les repas
entre amis qu mes parents organisent
alors bon ça c'est cool je vais complet
à chaque fois mais je fais surtout
complètement n'importe quoi et c'est pas
très longtemps après que ma mère
m'emmène passer un test de qi dans un
village juste à côté de chez nous qui
s'appelle lauzière je me suis vraiment
de ce moment parce que c'est là qu'on a
compris que j'utilisais ma mémoire un
petit peu différemment
vient ensuite la période du collège
alors j'avais pas beaucoup d'amis on va
pas se le cacher j'étais pas le mec
super populaire mais j'avais accès au
cdi et ça j'étais content j'avais quand
même quelques potes un peu barré aussi
je vous rassure mais c'est vraiment au
lycée après au lycée léon ix e jeu de la
rochelle que je découvre vraiment la
joie des potes des filles des soirées
des abus et donc du redoublement et
ouais les mecs je vais redoubler ma
seconde mais au bénéfice de découvrir
que je savais me faire des amis donc au
final je regrette pas avian juge ait eu
aussi des groupes de musique le plus
importante ces groupes là était il ya
d'acquis pour moi s'il ya des gens qu'on
connut yade acquis des kilos dans les
commentaires on faisait pas mal de
concerts dans la région et même en
dehors c'était vraiment cool et j'ai pas
continuer mes études après lycée c'est
le alors le système colère ça a jamais
été trop mon kiff j'ai préféré me former
dans les livres sur le terrain dans des
formations spécifiques
j'aime vraiment beaucoup à apprendre
mais j'aime quand c'est efficace et
danse après j'ai enchaîné des choses
vraiment très variés à 17 ans j'étais
formateur baffe en pays de la loire et
sur le tout le territoire national
à 18 ans je faisais le marché en vendant
des nappes 100% polyester antitaches
infroissable un coup d'épongé au
quotidien les imams c'est pas cher à 19
ans je fais un passage en restauration
avec mon pote denis on était les seuls à
la rochelle avoir un restaurant qui
faisait du savoyard et ça s'appelait la
petite souris
on s'est vraiment bien marrer et c'était
un bon moyen pour moi d'être en contact
chaque jour de nouvelles personnes pour
comprendre aussi comment fonctionnent
les relations sociales jusqu'au jour où
j'ai voulu changer
c'est un des points de mon
fonctionnement c'est que j'aime vraiment
découvrir les choses différentes mais au
bout d'un moment si je commence à en
faire le tour je veux changer je repars
souvent de zéro dans des nouvelles
aventures j'ai ensuite en vrac ou vers
une société d'animation à domicile
je faisais aussi de la magie du
mentalist pour des événements privés ce
qu'on appelle de l'événementiel et petit
à petit j'ai commencé à travailler à
l'étranger
j'ai beaucoup travaillé à l'étranger
entre mentalist à voir sur scène soit
sur les formations sur le non verbal sur
la mémoire aussi et surtout les sujets
sur lesquels je m'étais passionné depuis
presque l'enfance bref choisi une
trentaine de pays par an et c'est en
même temps que j'ai découvert le plaisir
de faire des spectacles d'humour grâce à
un pote qui s'appelle michel coubard et
qui m'a emmené sur scène sur le festival
du rire de saint martin de tahiti michel
si tu regarde cette vidéo je te dédie
cette vidéo parce que tu es un peu aussi
mon mon parrain là dessus et en 2011 je
pose mes valises à paris
et comme je suis à paris je me dis tiens
je vais peut-être essayer de m'occuper
en faisant du théâtre elle commence à
jouer dans un théâtre qui s'appelle la
comédie des trois bornes c'est un
spectacle que j'avais écrits qui
s'appelait maux de tête et j milan j'ai
vraiment humour magie et mentalisme en
pensant que le mentaliste n'allait pas
trop intéressé les gens et je me suis
complètement plantée comme ça c'était
pas une bonne prédiction d'antalis
puisque très rapidement j'ai supprimé la
magie pour ne laisser que le mentalisme
m'entourer de personnes pour m'aider et
le spectacle devient fabien olicard vous
mentalise que j'ai joué jusqu'à 7 m il
s'est passé des trucs de ouf depuis 2011
jusqu'à aujourd'hui j'ai joué au point
virgule au grand point virgule j'ai joué
au québec j'ai joué à l'olympia sur le
plateau du point virgule j'ai joué
partout en france j'ai fait des
rencontres de ouf j'ai vu l'envolée de
mon pote jeff pana club depuis les
cabarets jusqu'au zénith où j'ai fait
ses premières parties pour ses trois
premiers et need
et puis j'ai eu envie de changer je
voulais pas continuer comme ça donc je
me suis mis à écrire d'autres choses
avec des nouvelles envies toujours dans
l'humour et le mentalisme est quelque
chose qui me ressemble un peu plus pour
me stimuler dans l'écriture je me suis
lancé le défi de faire une vidéo par
jour sur un an
juste pour voir si j'étais capable de
faire ça et je décide donc à ce moment
là de mettre mes vidéos sur youtube
puisqu'il c'est la seule plateforme
d'hébergement de vidéos que je connaisse
vraiment mais je connais pas réellement
ce qu'est youtube
c'est après au mois de janvier que j'ai
découvert tout l'univers youtube et
ensuite c'est vous que j'ai découvert
c'est la première fois que j'explique
mon parcours en entier quelque part donc
c'est une vraie mise à nu je sais que
j'ai transformé ce mot mais c'était une
vraie mise à nu et je vous assure 2017
et plein de projets et de défis plus en
parlerait dans une prochaine vidéo début
janvier dans tout mon parcours j'ai
également rencontré des gens d'un talent
incroyable
c'est le cas de zapata c'est mon pote
peintre mais peintre c'est réducteur
c'est un artiste complet et c'est un
cadeau incroyable qui m'a fait en
participant à cette vidéo faite moi le
cadeau d'aller visiter sa chaîne donc
ce jour je ne sais pas exactement quand
je vais vous faire une vidéo pour vous
annoncer exactement ce qu'on va faire en
2017 si je me donne des nouveaux défis
ou pas si je continue à faire des vidéos
ou pas n'oubliez pas de cliquer sur la
cloche si on bat pour être sûr d'être
notifiés quand cette vidéo la sortira
maintenant les amis c'est moi qui vais
vous mettre un pouce en l'air c'est moi
qui vous envoie comme commentaire merci
beaucoup d'avoir été là tout cette année
en faisant une vidéo par jour je pensais
que ça m'amènerait au plus profond de
moi et que j'allais me rencontrer et à
la place c'est plus de deux cent trente
huit mille amis que j'ai rencontré mercy
j'ai la chance d'avoir une communauté
présente bienveillante intelligente j'ai
eu 366 rendez vous avec vous cette année
et je vais vous dire un secret c'est que
le début le mandat le blog c'était une
vidéo par jour pendant un an du 1er
janvier au 31 décembre
mais rendez vous bientôt ciao